el comandante Gary coordina las
maniobras de estos vehículos blindados
hacen parte de la brigada 28 que
defiende las posiciones en el sur de
bacmut actualmente hacen parte de la
ofensiva que ha logrado recuperar
territorio alrededor de la ciudad
entrenar es importante la mayoría de las
pérdidas se dan porque la gente no está
preparada
Solo han pasado tres días desde que
estos hombres regresaron del frente a
donde volverán en menos de una semana
mientras al menos 9 brigadas han sido
entrenadas en los últimos meses por las
fuerzas de la otan en el extranjero
ellos no tienen otra opción que preparar
la contraofensiva en medio de la batalla
no solo los recién llegados aprenden
también los soldados experimentados
aumentan su nivel estudian sus errores y
aprenden de ellos porque la guerra
siempre está cambiando esta brigada ha
estado destinado algunos de los frentes
más difíciles desde el comienzo de la
guerra muchos de sus integrantes han
quedado heridos o han fallecido
en los últimos meses han sido reforzados
con nuevos hombres que rápidamente
tienen que acoplarse a La tropa con más
experiencia
practicamos actividades de asalto para
eso se requiere aprender a golpear al
enemigo y a no tenerle miedo ellos son
los que tienen que tenernos miedo
el comandante Diego lleva combatiendo
desde comienzos de la invasión en 2014
para entonces nunca había estado en el
frente una situación idéntica a la que
se enfrentan estos hombres entrenan su
mayor rato es que pierdan el miedo y
ganen confianza cuanto antes
la primera prioridad es transferirles
conocimiento un punto importante es que
prestamos atención a la profesión que
tienen en su vida civil y Tratamos de
acoplar sus conocimientos a las
actividades militares en otro Rincón de
esta planicie Marina enseña Cómo evacuar
a los heridos en combate si saben hacer
un torniquete y controlar el estrés en
los momentos difíciles lograrán salvar
muchas vidas
muchas veces los nuevos no entienden la
importancia del entrenamiento aún así
los preparamos Pero al final de todo
depende del empeño que le ponga la
persona si hay una lección que les ha
dejado estos 15 meses de guerra Es que
la principal clave para sobrevivir es un
buen entrenamiento